And this is the first sentence.
Drink the last cup of coffee.
Hmm...
Huh?
Hey, grab home.
Wake up!
Did you do Mrs. B's homework?
Oh man, I stayed up too late playing Marvel Rivals, so I need a copy of yours real quick.
Hey.
Wait, Dragoon.
Wait, where did...
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
I need a copy.
I need a copy of his homework.
Is that you over there, Dragoon?
What...
What are you doing underneath that desk, huh?
You don't want me to stuff you in that locker again.
Come on!
Mrs. B is gonna be here any minute now.
Come on, get out of there!
Underneath that desk!
Look.
Look, Dragoon.
I can't get another detention or I'll miss a soccer practice.
And they're gonna cut me from the team.
Okay?
So, come on!
Hand me over...
Hand over the homework so I can copy off of you.
Hello?
Hey!
Are you like some kind of pervert?
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Are you...
Bro, like...
What?
Are you some kind of pervert or something?
Get out of here!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
What do you mean you ate the homework?
Come on!
Mrs. B is gonna be here any minute now!
I need you to get out of underneath that desk and help me with this homework.
Hello?
Don't make me bend down there.
Dragoon, come on.
Get out of there.
Get out of there, Dragoon.
Come on.
Oh my god.
I can't believe you made me bend down just to see if you were underneath that desk.
What do you mean there was homework?
I know you did that homework, you goddamn nerd.
Come on.
Move.
Move out of that desk.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm bending down.
Hello?
Dragoon?
I'm gonna count to three.
And you're gonna... you're gonna get out of that desk.
Alright?
Dragoon?
I am going to count to three.
One.
Two.
Three.
Oh my god.
Why are you... why are you still looking down?
Why are you... why are you still looking down, Dragoon?
My face is up here.
Come on.
Look, I need you... look.
I know we have like...
like...
pre-calculus or something.
And I almost failed.
I almost failed pre-calculus.
And I know you're the...
you're the best math goon out here.
Out of all of us.
So, I... I don't even remember.
Wait, is the Pytharious theorem part of pre-cal...
Oh my gosh.
What even is in pre-calculus?
Wait...
Look, I can't get cut from my soccer team.
Alright?
I'm literally...
their only goalkeeper.
If I get cut...
from the soccer team...
like...
that team's through.
Like, who's gonna be goalie now?
You think...
you think...
a goon's gonna be...
gonna be a good goalie?
He's basically our ball practice.
Uh...
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
You wanna go back down the desk?
What are you looking at my...
Oh my...
God!
If I didn't need a...
copy your homework...
I'd kick you right now.
I...
Oh my god.
Alright.
Come on.
Look back up.
Yes.
There you go.
You're almost there.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
If only...
All the other...
I know you're like...
like...
the best...
at pre-cal...
or math class.
Uh...
And like...
every time I copy your homework...
like...
I always get like...
a decent grade.
So I really...
really need you...
to focus up...
right now...
and hand me that piece of paper.
Um...
The bell's gonna ring...
at...
any minute now.
Come on.
You know how much money...
my parents paid me...
to...
to get me into...
Dragoon Academy?
Yeah.
Because it was...
definitely not for my test scores.
It...
So...
you gotta...
You gotta let me copy that.
I don't wanna...
I don't...
I can't get kicked out of...
Dragoon Academy.
Look, my parents paid a lot of money...
for me to be here.
And...
I didn't even need to take any...
tests...
to get in.
I literally got in because...
because of...
nepotism...
and money.
So you gotta...
hurry up and cough up those papers...
real quick.
Uh...
Alright.
You're almost there.
You're...
I don't know.
Um...
Excuse me.
I don't...
Um...
Excuse me.
I don't like being called a...
nepo baby.
I am a nepo woman.
Oh my...
I don't like you staring at me...
for so long.
Let me...
I don't like this.
Let me put...
put this on real quick.
Alright.
Got my jacket on.
That's right.
I don't like you staring at...
staring at me this long.
It makes me feel a little uncomfortable.
I am a nepo adult.
Anyway, it was getting a little cold too.
Um...
So...
I gotta...
gotta put on my hoodie...
slash jacket on.
Um...
Custom made, by the way.
to represent our...
our mascot...
Dragoon...
at the Dragoon Academy.
me.
Alright.
You're almost there.
You're...
Come on.
I need you to look at my face.
I need you to look up there.
Come on.
Oh my gosh.
That's it.
You're...
I'm gonna tweet about you.
That's it.
You're pissing me off.
I'm gonna tweet about you real quick.
What am I?
Typing right now?
Don't worry about it.
That's right.
If you don't cough up those papers...
I'm gonna send this tweet out...
right now.
I...
What you gotta do?
Go to the counselor?
Ha!
I won't...
I'll make sure you won't even make it to the counselor.
We're getting...
That's right.
You don't wanna get canceled, do you?
Ha!
Alright.
Okay, you're ready?
You're ready?
Alright.
You're almost there.
Wow.
You're almost...
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Wait, who's that over there?
Oh.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Look, it's our...
It's our class president.
Dad.
It's our...
It's our class president.
Hello, dad.
What'd you do?
No, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm not...
I'm just saying hi to Chonky-goon.
Uh, dad.
I'm...
There's...
There's nothing to worry about.
Uh...
There's...
Nothing to worry about.
We're just...
We're just friends.
Right?
Chonky-goon?
I'm just being a good friend right now.
And like...
Oh, man.
Like...
Dad, I like...
Forgot my...
I forgot to like...
Uh...
Answer like...
One of my questions...
For Mrs. B's homework.
So like...
I was just asking...
Chonky-goon...
If...
Um...
You know...
If he knew the answer to like...
Question 5.
That's really it.
Uh...
But yeah.
No, no, no, no.
We're...
We're just like...
Hang out.
You know?
There's...
The bell's about to ring any minute.
Just wanted to...
Wanted to say hi...
To Chonky-goon.
Want to know...
How his day's been going.
And...
Uh...
And like...
You know...
I...
Just wanted to know what he's gonna be doing after school.
Uh...
If he's gonna be alone after school.
You know?
I do that.
That's basically it.
That...
Yeah.
Don't worry, Mr. Class President.
I'll make sure...
I'll...
I'll make sure he'll be safe.
Don't worry.
Keep yourself safe.
Chonky-goon.
Keep...
All right.
Goodbye, Class...
Mr. Class President.
Goodbye.
All right.
He's gone.
Class President's gone.
You thought you were gonna...
You thought...
Get out of that?
You really think...
That's right.
You could get away...
With not letting me...
Copy your homework.
Come on.
Give me your bag right now.
Ha ha ha.
That's right.
What's that you got there?
Is that your...
Your dessert for lunch?
Give it here.
It's my dessert now.
Ha ha ha.
That's right.
You thought...
You thought that was yours?
It's mine now.
That's what you get...
For not giving me your homework to copy.
Wow.
What?
What is it?
Huh?
That's right.
I finished the lollipop too.
So anyway.
It's my birthday today.
Did you get me anything?
Oh, yeah?
Is that your lunch money?
Oh, it's my lunch money now, nerd.
Oh my god, wait.
Look what you did with your lollipop, chongoon.
Look what you did.
There's a stain on my hoodie now.
Oh my gosh, I guess...
I guess I got it.
It's a good thing I always bring a spare.
You're so lucky I have a spare jacket.
Wait until I tell my dad about you.
Yeah, you got here with a scholarship?
Well, say goodbye to that scholarship, chongy-coon.
I'm going to tell my dad about you.
That's right.
And I don't mean dad as in our class president.
I mean my father.
That's right.
Ever wonder why?
Why?
I still haven't been kicked out yet.
That's fucking right.
I'm going to tell my father about you.
Say goodbye to that scholarship.
You want to know who donates the most money to Dragoon Academy?
I mean that's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
Now give me your lunch money.
Happy birthday to me.
Happy birthday dear dokey bird.
Yeah!
Come on, chongy-coon.
Sing with me.
Yes, it's my birthday.
Yippee!
Let me put my...
Hold you down.
Hello, everybody.
Alright, roleplay over.
I didn't know how to transition out of it.
I don't know.
This is as far as I planned.
My...
The immersion ends here.
The...
The immersion...
End...
Scene.
The immersion ends here, guys.
Hello!
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
To my birthday outfit reveal.
This...
The beach episode has finally ended.
We are done with the filler arc.
And now we are...
Now we are here.
In my school arc.
Uh...
Yes!
Do you like my new outfit?
I know it's only been...
Two weeks.
I can't believe you guys ruined my poll.
I had...
So I had like...
All the questions planned out for a poll.
But after you guys ruined the first poll...
I just...
I pulled a plug on it.
I was like...
No more polls for you guys.
No.
That's right.
Do you guys like...
Do you guys like my new outfit, guys?
My...
Um...
Schoolgirl outfit.
Wait, let me...
From...
For the Dragoon Academy.
Let me zoom up for you guys to see.
I know it was like a super fast...
It was super fast reveal because...
We actually have...
A lot of stuff planned for today.
Um...
So that's why I...
I did zoom in a lot.
But like...
There really wasn't like...
That much to show.
Other than like...
The jacket part.
And...
Um...
The hair.
So...
I did...
I did like...
Zoom in a lot there.
But...
Um...
I do have a lot...
A lot of stuff to show you guys.
For today.
Uh...
For my birthday.
Thank you everybody for coming to my birthday.
Yeah, I did...
Plan...
Part.
I didn't know how to end it.
Like...
I know I could have done a whole actual scenario.
Where I stuffed you in a locker.
But like...
We don't have a lot of time.
Because I have a lot of stuff to show you guys.
Like...
There's...
There's a lot of stuff.
So that's why I was like...
Okay.
Scene's over.
Roleplay over.
Um...
But yes...
Okay, so...
If you guys didn't know...
This is the...
I can take it off.
Obviously.
Um...
We are in...
If you guys didn't know...
Dragoon Academy.
Uh...
For...
Um...
So like...
You gotta be very, very smart...
To be able to...
Get into...
Dragoon Academy.
And...
Uh...
Here you go.
You guys can see.
There's like...
Stuff on my bag here.
Little...
Uh...
Keychains.
My little charms.
And everything.
And then...
Uh...
I have...
Of course I have a...
I have a plush...
A keychain of...
You know...
Of our mascot.
Our Dragoon mascot.
In Dragoon Academy.
So you either have to be like...
A Nepo baby.
Or like...
Get a scholarship.
Or be really, really smart.
To be...
Get into Dragoon Academy.
And here's my shoes.
And everything.
Uh...
So...
Um...
The one thing I...
Def...
I requested...
Was...
As you guys can see...
Is like...
My phone here.
Anytime...
I click anything...
I'm tweeting out...
I'm...
Um...
I'm tweeting something out.
So...
I'm...
I'm making a Google Doc...
Right now...
To cancel you.
That's what I'm doing.
That's right.
He tried to...
Try to fuck with me.
I'm making a Google Doc right now.
Uh...
That's goddamn right.
So every time I click...
Um...
It does like...
And that...
It does a thing where it seems like I'm tweeting right now.
Which I am.
Uh...
Yes, it's my birthday.
Happy birthday to me.
Thank you, everybody.
For coming here to celebrate my birthday.
It really does mean a lot.
So...
I think like...
It was so hard to pick between...
Um...
Which one I wanted.
So...
I thought they were both really cute.
I have...
You know...
I have the...
Dragon hoodie right here.
And then...
Um...
I have the tomato hoodie as well.
I think the red really goes really well.
So it was very hard to pick between the two.
I was actually...
Okay.
Funny story.
A lot of things went wrong.
Okay.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
Um...
Actually...
A lot of things actually sort of like went wrong.
Uh...
For this birthday outfit reveal.
Because...
Um...
I was actually supposed to have a...
Uh...
A second...
Hairstyle.
And then...
We found out today...
This morning...
That...
My mama...
Forgot to send me...
The second hairstyle.
And I didn't realize it.
And then...
So yeah...
My papa...
Didn't realize there was a second hairstyle.
So...
That's why we don't...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
But I still...
I still like this one though.
I do like this hairstyle as well.
I look like very...
I look like delinquent.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Wait.
With the...
Uh...
Wait.
With the...
What are you looking at?
Huh?
Hmm?
That's right.
Walk away!
You want me to tell my father about you?
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
There's also...
The tomato one is a little silly.
Because like...
You know...
It's a little more silly.
But the...
Uh...
But the dragoon hoodie...
It looks more...
You know...
It looks more like...
Like...
Uh...
The class bully.
I'm...
Huh?
Hmm.
Ha ha ha ha.
And then...
Put down.
Ha ha ha.
And then...
What about it?
That's right.
What are you looking at?
You're here to give me your lunch money?
Ha ha ha.
That's right.
WAH!
If you're not here to give me my lunch money!
And then, obviously, so...
This was something...
I wanted to do for a while.
Because...
You know, it's really hard to include Dad...
In streams, because, you know, when he's on top of my head...
He takes up so much of my space.
So, I just... I wanted him to, like...
I wanted him to, like...
Actually, I could actually, like...
Not have him take up majority of my space.
Uh...
So...
So, I was just like...
Okay, you're...
Can I have...
Hold him?
Can I hold Mr. Class President?
Yeah, so...
So, look at him.
Look at him go.
Oh, wait, here.
Let me show you his feet for free.
Alright.
Look at how long he is!
He's so long!
Look at him!
Wow!
He's such a long boy!
Oh, yeah.
I could take this off, too.
Wow!
Look at this long boy!
Long, long boy!
Um...
But, yeah.
I don't...
I know, like...
No comment.
Also, so, another bad luck thing happened to me.
Um...
I was actually supposed to have...
A...
Um...
A custom background, too.
But, the person who was making my custom background...
Had a...
Family Emergence...
I know, I didn't...
I'm not supposed to laugh at that.
But, I just thought it was funny how...
Unlucky I've been for this outfit reveal.
So...
He had a...
Family Emergence.
So, that's why I had to, like, try and find...
I had to find a background, too.
So...
So, this is what the background was supposed to look like.
And I was supposed to, like, be at your desk.
I...
You know...
I can't...
This was supposed to be...
But, it will be done.
Um...
It will be done, eventually.
It just didn't make it in time.
For...
Uh...
I'm laughing because of how unlucky I was.
And...
So...
Um...
But, yes, it's gonna...
This is what the background was supposed to look like.
And there was gonna be, like...
You know...
Other...
Other students and everything.
But, you know, that's just something to look forward to.
When it does come.
You know?
Um...
Anyway, we have...
What have I been?!
I'm sorry!
Sorry, I was...
Sorry, I was just roleplaying.
I was roleplaying as the class bully.
Guys, I...
That...
Sorry, I...
I got too into the character.
What's that word called?
When...
When you're an actor and you got, like, too into the character.
You're...
Sorry.
I was just...
Uh...
I was doing method acting, guys.
It was just method acting, everybody.
I swear to God.
I...
But anyway.
Um...
So...
I will show you guys...
Wait, I actually wrote a list of all this...
Oh!
Before...
Um...
Before I show you the, uh...
Behind the scenes stuff.
Um...
I do have something special to give you guys.
So...
Uh...
If you guys didn't know...
Um...
Well, the new outfit comes with a new wallpaper!
Yes!
So...
Uh...
I am releasing a new wallpaper...
For...
Uh...
For you guys.
So...
Yay!
I'll be posting...
I'll post a...
Download link.
I can't pin it because...
Okay.
Just so you guys know.
There is a very special announcement right after the stream.
So...
Uh...
So I'm gonna pin the wallpaper.
But just so you guys know.
There is a very special announcement...
At the...
Um...
At the end of the stream.
So like...
You got...
Be there or be square.
Uh...
So let me, uh...
So let's buy salt.
Uh...
Let me, uh...
Do this real quick.
So yes!
Free wallpaper!
So there is a...
And I also included...
The...
Concert...
Uh...
The concert...
Um...
Artwork too.
For your free wallpaper as well.
Uh...
But yes!
Here you go guys!
A free wallpaper for everybody!
Yay!
Um...
But that's not all.
Sorry.
There's a lot of announcements.
It's...
It's a...
This birthday...
There's a lot of stuff going on.
This birthday.
So...
Um...
I have a lot of stuff to show you guys.
I love free stuff!
Me too!
Okay, but the next...
A few things aren't free.
Uh...
The next couple of stuff may or may not be free, guys.
It may...
Okay, let me move to the side a little bit so I can properly show some stuff to you guys.
So...
Um...
Other thing...
Okay, so I'll talk about the behind the scenes stuff.
For...
Uh...
This new outfit.
Um...
So...
Originally, I wanted...
To have something related to...
I really...
I just wanted a hoodie.
Like a...
A mascot hoodie.
You know?
Just...
As a throwback.
Because I always thought they were super cute.
So...
I wanted...
Like...
A mascot hoodie.
And I gave like several ideas.
I was like...
It could be...
Dragoon.
Tomato.
It could be...
Croaky.
So...
Um...
To my mama.
And...
This is fully designed by my mama.
So...
These are the concept art that...
Uh...
She gave me.
And...
Um...
In terms of like...
Because I was like...
Oh, I really want...
I really wanted like...
Um...
Something related to like...
A hoodie.
That's sort of like...
You know?
Like a mascot hoodie.
I don't know why croaky's blue.
I...
I don't...
It wasn't...
Meant to be for...
A school themed.
I just wanted a casual wear.
Oh...
Wait.
Sorry.
My food's here.
Sorry guys.
I've been up since 10am prepping for...
I've been up since 10am prepping for this stream.
When I say there's a lot of stuff...
That's gonna be...
Announced.
Well, not announced.
But there's a lot of stuff that's gonna be going on...
For this birthday stream.
So like...
I've been awake since 10am prepping for the stream.
So...
So this will be my first meal of the day.
Um...
It's school lunch time!
School lunch time!
Anyway...
Um...
I saw concept C.
And then...
That...
Was what made me go...
I want a...
School outfit theme.
Because I got...
Super inspired by concept C.
So...
I sent in...
These were like...
My...
Um...
These were my...
Uh...
I guess...
What's the word?
Uh...
Inspirations.
So I sent...
These two pictures...
To my mama.
For like...
Inspirations.
And also like...
This as well.
To be like...
Oh yeah!
I want like a school uniform.
Um...
Because I never had a...
You know...
I never had a school themed...
Um... outfit before.
I just sent in...
Um...
Stuff like...
You know...
Animal hoodies.
And stuff like that.
Um...
And...
And then...
I really wanted...
Something where I was...
Holding my phone.
So...
My phone is actually...
Uh...
Decora.
I don't know if you...
Okay, so like...
Men might not know what this is.
But...
I've always wanted to do...
Um...
Decora phones.
So it's basically like...
Uh...
I do!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
We can learn!
Uh...
Okay.
Decodent.
Or...
Decocases.
And...
Uh...
So I've always wanted...
I've always wanted to like...
Do...
It's basically like an arts and crafts shit.
Where you...
There's like cafes themed around like...
Uh...
Deco cases.
And like...
You just sit down and like...
They give you like...
These icing pipes.
And like...
That are like plastic...
That are filled with like...
Plastic and stuff.
And...
Uh...
30% girl gang!
Rise up!
And then you sit down and like...
Decorate like...
A clear phone case.
And they'll have like...
Charms and everything.
And...
Uh...
Little charms...
And like...
Little decorations.
And stuff like that.
So that's my phone case right here.
So...
That's what was the...
Inspiration...
For...
Um...
For the phone.
And that was like the one thing.
I was like...
I must have...
A...
A deco phone case.
That is dragon themed.
Uh...
Because I love our school mascot.
So much!
And then of course...
I was like...
I would like an outfit for dad.
And then my mama drew this.
And I was like...
Perfect!
Uh...
Our little class president.
I love...
And so...
After I said...
I wanted a...
Squib...
Um...
Outfit themed.
Uh...
My...
Okay...
My mama sent me...
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I cut dad in half.
But like...
Don't worry.
There's a reason why.
Um...
I sent in...
Uh...
My mama sent...
This to me.
So...
Um...
As you can see...
We were also supposed to have...
Hairstyle...
Too.
Um...
But...
We sort of forgot...
It went missing...
During...
It was forgot...
Like...
I think like...
It was either like...
Um...
Cause I don't know...
We don't know if it was like...
My mama...
Was like...
Oh wait.
Let me try and find it.
So I haven't heard...
Like...
Uh...
I didn't get another email yet.
About like...
What happened to the missing hairstyle.
Uh...
But yes.
We're supposed to have hairstyle...
Too.
As well.
Uh...
Um...
But...
It's gonna be added later.
So...
Just like the...
Background...
Um...
Just like the background...
We're gonna have...
The second hairstyle...
At a later time.
Uh...
No.
I read the email.
But like...
Um...
I'm waiting for the...
The next email.
About like...
The new...
The hairstyle.
Where it went.
Cause it wasn't in our files.
Like...
It wasn't in any of the files I was sent.
So we're...
So I'm waiting for the email...
Of like...
Where...
What happened to the second hairstyle.
Hahaha.
So...
It's tomato time.
Anyway...
So, as you guys can see, we were trying to decide, like, the school uniform.
And I decided, you know, I wanted it not to be a tie.
I wanted it to be a ribbon.
And then you can see that, you know, basically the concept was there already.
Like, we didn't really change much till the final version.
And then after that, the final version was...
Whoa, what happened?
Okay.
Let's switch the final version after that.
So...
So, we were supposed to have, you know...
Oh, yeah, I also changed the phone case color because I didn't like the blue in the end.
But...
But yes, this is basically what it ended up looking like in the end.
So, you can see that, you know, like...
From... for Dragoon Academy.
Oh, wait, my vest.
What happened to my...
From Dragoon Academy.
So...
Um...
But yeah, I thought it was...
I thought it turned out really good in the end.
I'm really happy with how it came out.
And I...
I love... I was like, I want a lollipop.
Because I looked how much of a...
Um...
I looked at how much, you know...
I was like...
Like, you know...
Like a delinquent.
So I was like, oh, I gotta get lollipop in too.
So I can be like...
By the way...
Um...
I can...
Do other stuff with it as well.
So...
Let me...
Let me put the hoodie down.
So...
Um...
I can...
My other stuff works for it as well.
So...
Can you give me your lunch money?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
And obviously...
You know...
Dad and his...
Mr. Class President on my head too.
There's Mr. Class President.
And...
Um...
Let's see.
Ooh...
Oh my gosh.
And then...
Yeah?
Ha ha ha!
Of course!
I am the star student of Class 1A.
Of course I am!
Or who is it?
DA.
Ha ha ha!
D1.
Of course!
I'm so innocent!
Ha ha ha!
Me?
Bullying?
Changkun?
I couldn't have done that Mrs. B.
Look at me!
Ha ha ha!
And then...
Who tattled on me?
Who's that snitch?
Ha ha ha!
Oh yeah.
And...
By the way...
um...
This also works...
And...
The best part is that...
It also works...
With a hoodie.
Ha ha ha!
It works...
It...
It..
It works with the hoodie as well.
So...
Yay!
Alright, let me... let me get back... back to... back to short neck here.
And then, blank eyes.
And...
Wait, what's this?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, I'm not a nerd, alright?
I just have really bad eyesight, okay?
I just play too much video games.
I'm not a nerd like you.
That's different.
I'm not like one of you.
Call me a nerd one more time, I'm gonna stuff you in that locker.
And then, this one might...
I don't know, every time... every time it's like that, I like to be like...
And then... oh my god.
Oh...
Mrs. B gave too much homework.
I have to...
I have to stay up and do...
Algebra.
And then, obviously, I have, you know...
These...
Jesus, if you're here.
Algebra.
And of course...
Dough Kitty.
Dough Kitty's school art.
War...
But thank you, thank you guys.
So thank you everybody for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you everyone.
But yes, Dough Kitty is also here as well.
And I think like...
I think those are...
I mean, they're definitely not all the Tagos.
But...
This is one of...
Some of them that I can show you guys.
So, I know I'm like...
Sort of zooming a little bit.
But you'll understand later.
You'll understand later.
But...
You know...
Remember when I said...
Uh...
Remember when I said that...
There's a lot of stuff to show you guys.
This isn't an announcement.
But like...
There's a lot of stuff I want to go through with you guys.
For my birthday.
And...
One of them...
Is...
Is that...
We have finally...
Relaunched...
The Dough Kitty merch website!
Yes!
Also, my third monitor died again!
Woo!
Oh my god, sorry.
I almost...
I'm a mess right now!
I'm a mess!
But...
Dough Kitty merch has been...
Fli...
Fully relaunched...
In a way that...
Our distributor has finally finished...
Um...
Doing...
Doing all the logistics...
Off of...
Uh...
For Dough Kitty merch.
So...
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I dropped my...
My...
I'm a little silly today.
I don't...
I'm a little silly.
The...
My steam deck...
Uh...
So I need to remember how to...
Place my steam deck.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
And I need to fix my third monitor.
Cause I can't look at...
Chat.
Uh...
Third monitor!
Why are you not working?
It has been like...
A little bit of a nuisance.
I might have to change my monitor.
Um...
I think it's cause like...
All three of my monitors are super...
Uh...
Are super powerful.
And it like...
I don't think my PC can handle it.
I...
Um...
There you go.
Yay!
I can see...
I can see you guys now!
Yay!
Uh...
So...
We have...
A lot of drops happening right now...
On Doki Merch.
So...
Here's another thing.
I guess it's another thing to...
Um...
To...
To pin right now for you guys.
So...
Uh...
I'll show you guys real quick.
On all the stuff.
For...
Doki Merch!
Uh...
Make sure everything is good.
Alright.
So...
Doki Merch.
Doki Merch, show up!
Doki Merch?
Hahahaha!
Oh, there you go!
Oh, ok.
There you go.
Doki Merch!
Hello, Doki Merch!
So, as you guys can see...
Uh...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let me...
As you guys can see...
Uh...
We have...
A big launch.
A big website launch.
So...
This is our new distributor.
We actually have some of the items in stock...
Uh...
Right now.
So, if you order some of the items right now, including the... I think the gibbets... yeah.
We have some of them in the warehouse at the moment.
Oh, do you guys see this?
Yes, it's the birthday bundle!
Yes!
Sorry, it's in Canadian.
But, so the birthday bundle includes artwork drawn by my... oh, my monitor died again.
Goddammit!
Okay, drawn by my mama!
And it includes from this bundle.
You can buy all these individually, by the way.
But, you can get a postcard, which comes with a bundle.
So, by buying this bundle, you get the postcard.
It gets the checky.
There's a patch for Dragoon Academy.
So, you can grab the... it's like an embroidered patch for Dragoon Academy.
And there's a really cute... look at this chibi stand!
It's so cute!
Uh... yeah, it's 76 Canadian.
So, that's like 8 US dollars, right?
So, yes!
A lot of items for the birthday bundle.
But, that's not all.
As you guys can see, we have... oh, this one.
So, this one was actually from you guys.
You guys made the... uh... the happy.
Uh... and we loved it so much that we made it an official merch.
So, it is a little bit different from the fan merch.
But, this one is... um... this one is basically... uh... the happy that... and we replaced the text with our logo.
And we added in... I think... I don't remember which one we added in.
But, uh... from the... but we made it an an official... uh... an official happy.
For those who are wondering if the checkies are hand signed...
For this collection, I did not... I did not... um... do any autographed items.
Because I am... right now... really swamped.
Right now!
I am... I am... I am... I am... I am sorry.
I was so swamped the last... the last couple of months.
I couldn't... I couldn't sign anything.
Um... but we also... not only that, but you can also get the retro Doki plushie!
Right now!
Okay, not right now.
This is pre-order.
But... this is a pre-order item.
But, for those who don't know, this... my distributor is Gamersupps.
So, like, you know, they're very trusting and everything.
So, you know, we're not in the mess that we were in last year.
Uh... so they do have some items in the warehouse right now.
And I believe... if you go to live in stock...
We are bringing... we brought back the Bounty Hunter acrylic stand, too!
So you can basically... all these items that you see right now...
Um... we have these three items in the warehouse at the moment.
So you can basically order these and you'll receive it.
Um... um... so if you guys... you know what?
The Doki... the Doki Bounty Hunter acrylic sand...
The gibbets... uh... and the... uh... red pocket envelopes.
Um... the other stuff we have... so here's the pre-order.
Um... we have a Christmas sweater.
By the way, the photo looks really dark, but they're actually a lot lighter.
And it's really... it's really comfy.
And then... oh, I love this one.
This is the... the desk mat.
So, um... this is one of my favorite Japanese artists.
Uh... so... here is like... a... um... a little... really... uh... what's the word called?
Aesthetic desk mat.
You know, with all these colors and all these dragoons and everything.
So, we have this really cute desk mat too that you can get right now.
And then look at this dragoon beanie!
So, if you're a beanie user, we have a dragoon beanie here too.
And then, oh, I love this chibi acrylic sand.
Look at this sand.
It's so cute.
So, it's a three-piece.
So, there's the background that's themed around this outfit.
So, there's me taking a selfie with Mr. Class President.
And he's very easily bribed by the way.
Just kidding.
But here's the little chibi set.
I thought it was super cute.
And also, you can purchase the Hawaiian dog shirt or pet shirt if you want to dress up your pet in a Hawaiian hot dog shirt.
You can get it now as well.
You can pre-order this right now too.
So, the one... Look!
See?
It's... Look!
Doki bird talk dog.
Aloha!
And, if you guys didn't see...
The retro Doki stand is also back.
And it's going to be there on the store forever.
So, if you haven't been able to get the retro stand, we are offering it now on the store as well.
And then there's the patch.
The embroidered patch.
Sorry.
The render is like...
This is a render right now.
We're still waiting for the sample at the moment.
But it's going to be a embroidered patch for the Dragoon Academy.
And there's the checky!
And then there's a secret message here.
I don't know if you can unblur this, but yes.
There's the... There's the checky with a secret message in the back and everything.
Yay!
But yeah!
I hope you guys are excited about... About the store... The new store.
I'm really happy.
We worked... Me... My staff team and Gamersupps worked incredibly hard on the launch of the store.
We actually... They actually, like... Um... Um... We're... We're working on it, like, a couple of hours ago.
They finished the store launch, like, I think an hour before the stream was about to go live.
So, that's what's like... They've been working on this website for, like, months.
And, um... We're fi... The fact that we're finally... It's finally launched!
Yay!
Oh, I thought this one was really cute.
So, if you go light mode... If you go light mode, it swaps to RetroDoki.
Um... And, obviously, I'm gonna add more to the gallery and everything.
And, um... Like, all the references of all my outfits.
And then these are all the people I've worked with.
And then there's the video gallery.
And... But yeah, I thought it was such a cute little feature.
When you swap to light mode, it's RetroDoki.
And then dark mode is me, because I guess I'm evil.
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Um... And then here would be the events calendar.
So, if you're like, oh, where is... Where is Doki...?
Where is Doki Bird?
You know, where is Carmen Sandia?
I don't know, Santiago.
You can look at the events and like, oh, that's where she is.
That's where she's gonna go right now.
But yes, I am super happy about the store launch and everything.
Look at all these.
Oh, the beanie is so cute.
But yeah, I hope you guys have a better experience now with my merch.
And yay, that's me!
Happy birthday, Jokey!
Yay!
But yes, this is all handled by Gamersupps for me.
So they are my distributor and they help me with making my ideas into reality.
So if you guys ever, you know, order stuff with Gamersupps, they've been like, you know, super...
They've been like really good with their customer service and also their, um, of how they handle merch and everything.
So yeah, I hope you guys, you know, have a more fun time and enjoy all the Jokey merch for your shrine!
Yay!
Alright, so yes, that is not the official announcement, by the way.
That was not the official announcement of what I was gonna tell you guys.
Because I have other stuff that I want to show you.
Uh, oh.
I got myself some cookies and cake.
So let me show you guys.
Uh, oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
But, um, let me show you guys, uh...
This little cake that I got.
Yay!
It's all of you guys!
Nice!
Also, that's like the evil goon with the knife ready to cut.
Look!
I gotta look at this cake I got!
Dragoons!
Isn't it cute?
Yeah, that's you!
Wait, actually, they said they would send me a video of the baking of the cake.
I don't know if they sent... Let me double check real quick.
Oh, wait, they did!
Oh my god!
Wait, let me see.
Oh, they did!
They sent the video of them making the cake!
Cake!
Okay, I'm downloading it right now.
Let's watch this together.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
I know, I'm so excited.
I'm really excited to try this cake out.
It looks so cute.
But yes, there's all... Look at all these... Look at all these little guys!
That's so cute!
Alright, let's see.
I should never...
My manager messaged me and was like... Careful!
Okay, let me send this video to my manager first.
And have them watch the video!
To be sure!
Because I can't watch it right now.
I...
I... I forgot the flavor.
I actually... I actually forgot what flavor it is.
But I thought...
This was super cute.
And like, if you see the side...
There's like mini dragoons on the side...
As well.
But not only that...
But I also got cookies made too!
Look!
Yeah, I got dra... Oh my gosh!
Okay, so...
For the cookies...
Um, I'm gonna show you guys the video for this.
But I asked them if they could give you guys the recipe...
On how to make your very own dragoon cookies as well.
That video I watched because they sent it to me super early.
But I...
Um, I'll show the video as well.
But...
Um, they basically made a little tutorial for all of us...
On how to make your very own dragoon sugar cookies.
So, I'll play that video right now as well.
Let me...
Let me play that for you guys.
I thought it was so cute.
I was like...
Oh my gosh!
I asked them like...
Um...
Oh, can you like...
Make a short video for us?
So like...
We can learn how to make these cookies?
And...
And she was like...
Yeah, of course!
Of course we can!
Uh, so if anyone wants to make their very own dragoon cookies...
Yay!
Chocolate sugar cookies!
Okay, um...
Give me a sec for me...
Oh my god!
It's so fast!
I realized...
I was like...
Wait, you can't even...
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay, there we go.
Now you can sort of see the instructions a little better.
Uh...
I was like...
When I'm covering like half the recipe...
Oh my god, is it really loud?
Okay, let me...
Turn it down.
So...
Uh...
Yeah, whisk to combine.
Set aside.
Next is the mixture.
Grab, stand, mixture.
Work.
Okay, so sugar, butter, two eggs, vanilla extract.
Put in green.
Look at that, we're all learning!
We're all learning together!
Yippee!
Bump, bump, bump.
Take notes, guys!
Take notes, you can make...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Take notes so you can make your own dragon cookies!
Okay, go!
Yay!
Oh, you can hear.
Okay, now you can hear me.
Wrap in plastic wrap!
Whoa!
Look at...
Look at them go!
Flat end dough after wrapping!
Are you taking notes?
One hour later!
Sprinkle flour on rolling surface!
Dust flour...
Oh my gosh!
Roll out...
Okay, you guys are gonna have to re-watch this.
You're gonna have to re-watch this later.
Oh, look, it's so cute!
Oh, and then like, print it all out.
And then they baked it.
Time to make the royal icing!
So they do...
Look at...
There it is.
There's all the ingredients.
Oh my god, wait.
She just like...
Wait, that's how you mix it?
I haven't baked in so long.
Ha ha ha ha!
Instructions unclear!
Ha ha ha!
Use that egg goon to make our...
Dragoon cookies!
It's just that easy, guys!
Ha ha ha!
All right, portion all of these.
Okay, but like, how much do I have to pour?
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, they're like the colors!
Okay, color matching might be difficult.
Ha ha ha!
Please...
Color matching might be a little bit difficult in here.
Ha ha ha!
Yippee!
Cannibalism!
Oh, and then they like...
They like...
Do outlines and stuff.
Okay, knowing me, I'm not gonna do any outlines.
Oh, I feel like I should do outlines though.
Ha ha ha!
My instructions are clear!
I made a hydrogen bomb!
Ha ha ha!
You can't bake cookies without breaking a few egg goons, Jack!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, you have to have like, such steady hands for this too.
Oh, keep going till all the cookies are decorated.
Oh, that's cute!
It's like they're going in one by one and then letting it dry.
Oh, look!
And then...
I ate one by the way.
The first cookie I ate was dead.
It was so good.
Ha ha ha ha!
But look, it's so cute!
Everything came out like so cute!
I'm happy.
But you know, I wanted to like, make this birthday a little special.
And then like, make it themed around you guys.
But alright, let's see the cake one too.
I don't think the cake one has a recipe.
So, um, I think it's just, you know, aesthetic cake baking.
Ooh!
Look!
Oh, that's cute!
Look at...
It's so tiny!
Oh my god!
Wait, I just realized I'm not wearing my dragoon hoodie.
Ha ha ha ha!
I'm talking about...
There you go.
Aww!
That's cute!
And then there's the whole gang!
It's step one!
Get a cake!
Step two!
Decorate!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's like, you know those tutorials where they're like, um, how to draw your favorite character.
Step one!
Draw a circle!
Step two!
It's done!
It's...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
But thank you everyone!
Thank you everyone!
For the...
Um...
For the Akasupas!
For the Super Chats in general!
And for all the members!
I really, really appreciate it everyone!
Thank you everybody!
It means so much that you're all here to celebrate my birthday with me!
Thank you guys!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Draw...
Draw two circles!
Draw the rest of the owl!
Yes!
Ha ha ha ha!
That's usually how it goes, right?
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Oh yes!
Uh...
Let me see it.
I have like a whole folder of like, remember to show these things!
Toki!
I remember to show it!
Uh...
Oh yes!
By the way!
Here is...
Uh...
So if you guys didn't know, here is the 3D models.
Of the costumes.
Of the school outfits.
Uh...
Done by...
Salted Fish.
Uh...
So...
Obviously for our...
Isekai...
Um...
Isekai video.
Uh...
Oh yeah!
So...
That was my idea.
Cause I was like...
Okay, how...
I like how...
I like doing these like little mini-series, you know?
Where like...
There's like, you know...
A story behind every outfit reveal.
So it's not just like...
Here's my outfit.
Like...
I...
But...
Like I said from the summer one.
Um...
I always love doing like a little...
Little story.
That goes between...
Each outfit reveal.
And...
Okay, this one was a little scuffed.
Cause I didn't know how to end.
I...
I felt like this could go on forever.
So I had to like...
Stop the...
Immersion.
And be like...
Okay, I have a lot of stuff to go through.
Like...
I can't...
I can't continue this story...
Anymore.
I...
There's...
You know, in the past I would...
It would...
The story would continue.
But I literally couldn't...
I...
I had so much stuff to talk to you guys about.
So I was just like...
Alright, we're stopping here.
We're...
To continue this...
This scenario...
You have to buy...
The DLC.
I'm sorry.
You've used up your credits by the way...
Dragoons.
You...
You've used up...
Your credits...
For...
For the school...
School...
Scenario.
Um...
And the DLC...
Noooo!
Uh...
But...
Yeah...
Uh...
So...
It was...
I had...
The idea...
Okay, so...
At first...
I need you guys to know...
For...
The video...
The funny thing about the video...
Was that...
Um...
It didn't...
At first it was just...
A regular tomato...
And then I was like...
Oh, can we make...
The tomato...
More...
God-like?
And then...
The...
Animator...
The video...
MB guy was like...
Um...
The video guy was like...
How do you...
What do you mean by that?
And then I drew this...
That...
This...
I...
I drew this...
Uh...
This is my reference...
To the...
Video editor...
I was like...
Can you make the tomato look like this?
As if he's like...
A fucking god...
Or some shit...
I drew this in MSB with my mouse...
I...
The...
Perfection...
Witness him...
Um...
But...
But yeah...
That's basically...
Uh...
Also...
Let me...
Put my ad...
Buy my merch...
Here's my...
Here's my ad...
By the way...
Time for an...
Time for an ad break...
You can't skip this ad...
You...
Um...
But...
Yeah...
Anyway...
Uh...
Can we have that as the wall...
Baby!
Uh...
But yes...
I am super...
Um...
Super...
Happy to spend...
Uh...
My birthday with...
My dragoons...
As always...
Because you guys always...
Uh...
Make me feel so happy...
Um...
Every day.
And, you know, happy being able to celebrate my special day with all of you guys!
Yay!
Who's the artist?
Oh my gosh.
I'll have them pull up the artists.
Because, like, they...
The team knew how I was super busy, so they didn't want to bother me while I was prepping for the streams for today.
And so I'll be giving them the list of all the artists.
Because I was the one that contacted all the artists.
So my team, the Gamersupps team, and my staff team that was in charge of the website, don't really know which artists I...
Which artists I contacted to make all the illustrations for the merch.
So I'll be giving them a list later.
They didn't want to bother me because I was, you know, I've been working since 10 in the morning.
But you guys might be like, Wait, 10 in the morning?
What have you been planning?
Jokey, why did it take you guys that long?
All right.
Um, there's one thing I didn't show you guys.
And it's this little gift right here.
So, I think it's time for the announcement.
Oh wait, before... JK.
It's actually green screen time.
Get baited.
I showed you the present.
And now, now you gotta wait after the green screen.
What's in the box, Jokey?
Also, we gotta figure out the colors, guys.
Again.
Okay, so...
Oh, that is really green.
What do we be?
Do we be purple?
No, but then there's my hair clip.
Guys, I have too many colors.
What color do we be?
Maybe like...
Dark blue?
Wait, what color can we be, guys?
My eyes.
The not green screen.
I don't know what color to be because there's so many colors.
I have too many colors on me.
Oh, dark purple?
Wait, we could be dark purple.
Let's see.
Maybe gray?
Wait, okay.
Let's try dark purple.
Okay, how do I...
Okay.
Let's try...
Um...
Okay, here we go.
Do you think that works?
Dark purple?
How about this purple?
You think that purple works?
Oh, but then my phone, though.
What about...
Yeah, my phone and my nails.
That's what I'm saying!
I have too many colors!
Oh, dark blue.
Oh, does this...
No, because...
What about my sweater?
What about my sweater, though?
What about this one?
Dark...
Dark green!
You're so right!
Okay, let's...
Get dark green.
Okay, uh...
There you go.
Do you think this works?
This should work, right?
Maybe this?
Do you think this will work?
The dark green screen?
Literally green.
Yeah, but my eyes!
My eyes are, like, light green.
Or should we do it?
Okay.
Darker?
That's as dark as we can go.
Here you go.
Do you think that works?
Okay.
All right!
All right, let me do...
Let me...
Okay, we should have some music.
All right, so there's me.
Fold me.
And then...
The tomato.
Yeah!
And then...
Eh!
And...
Me holding dad.
I like holding dad without the hoodie, though.
I feel like...
Hey!
Hey, look!
There he is!
Mr. Class President!
Uh...
He's not taking any questions!
Also, my food has been, like, outside my door for, like, the last hour.
All right, look at...
Okay, wait.
Here, you guys, look at dad for a sec while I get my food.
I'll be right back.
All right.
It took a while because, um...
Because I had to, like...
You know when they tie a really tight knot on the bag?
So I had to...
I had to...
Like, I was trying to...
I was trying to tie the knot.
I was like, I just clipped my nails!
I can't do this!
Okay.
All right.
Anyway.
Here's...
Wait, wait, let me see.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What are you looking at, huh?
All right.
How is that?
It's not that I like you or anything.
I'm a bugger.
I'm fucking cringy!
I could never roleplay.
All right.
I can't take myself seriously.
Now I eat.
I eat now.
Um, what else?
Oh, he knows I'm eating.
Mr. President, I'm sorry for eating.
Class president, I'm sorry for eating.
I'm outside at lunch hours, but I'm so hungry.
Okay, um, what else?
Oh, yeah, a tomato.
There's such an ugly fucking color, the green screen.
I'm just, there's too many colors.
I have, I have too many colors.
The green screen is so ugly compared to the screenshots.
No food in the classroom.
I'm sorry, Mr. Class president.
Oh, yeah, and then, um,
what?
Okay, now I do request.
Um, I'm doing requests now.
What do you guys want to see?
Guys.
Hmm?
Hmm.
What expressions do you guys want to see, guys?
While I eat my food.
Okay, the only way I'll ever...
I'll do the Jesus combo is if Jesus shows up.
On the third day, he shall rise.
So, whenever he shows...
If he shows up, I'll give you the combo.
Only if he shows up, though.
Um, I need...
That is only given to Jesus.
Where is he when we need him the most?
Where is he?
And the...
Oh, and the lollipop?
Sure.
Ha ha ha ha.
Jesus, don't go.
Praise the Lord.
Guys, I don't think Jesus is here, guys.
I don't think he's here.
Ha ha ha.
Um, all right.
We got the glasses.
All right, glasses done.
All right, what other...
I'll do five requests.
That's request number one.
What's request number two?
I've lost faith.
Ha ha ha ha.
He has disappointed me for the last time.
The face?
Okay.
Um.
Uh.
I mean, that's not you.
I know what...
Ha ha ha.
Identity stuff is not a joke, guys.
I...
Ha ha ha.
Yeah, I can do that.
Wait, let me...
Where am I hoodie?
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
That is not...
That is not Jesus.
You can't fool me.
I shall make Jesus request in this place.
No, it has to be from specifically Jesus.
It can't be...
No imposters.
We can't have...
We can't have any imposters of the Messiah.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
We are not here for heretics.
All right, whatever.
Okay, that's request number two.
Ha ha ha.
What's request...
I know what Jesus' profile picture looks like.
All right, what's request number three?
Yeah, I don't accept the false prophet.
I need...
I need the real deal.
Uh, we have Jesus at home.
Ha ha ha.
All right.
All right, let's see.
Long neck.
Ah.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Do not be afraid.
All right.
The false idols.
And then...
Oh my God, I'm so tired.
I'm so...
I'm so tired.
Guys.
I'm so...
I'm so tired.
Dragons.
I was up all night.
Cramming for the final.
I'm so tired.
Sorry, he knows I'm eating.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, no, kitty?
I got you.
I'm so tired.
Actually, me though.
Actually, me right now.
I'm so fucking tired.
Okay.
Om nom nom nom nom.
Om nom nom.
Mmm.
Okay.
Alright, what else do you guys want?
The dark circles...
The dark circles, guys!
Oh, it's too real!
The dark circles are too real!
It's giving you guys PTSD!
Alright, last request.
Last request, guys.
Before I give you guys the announcement.
Uh, for his commentary!
Is that right?
Is that right, Dad?
You wanna give some commentary?
Alright.
Uh...
Can you do the combo off screen?
Ha ha ha!
Whenever Jesus...
If Jesus ever shows up again, Uh, you'll...
You'll...
You'll get your combo.
But not...
If he doesn't, not today.
I'll give the combo whenever he shows up.
Oh, Dizzy.
I'll do...
What is it?
Last combo.
Ha ha ha ha!
There you go.
Alright.
Now it's announcement time.
Can I get a drum roll, please?
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba You know,
it's like a re-gift to, like, people who got something they didn't want, and then they re-gift it to, like, somebody's birthday or some shit.
They got a really shitty Christmas present, and then they re-gift it to something, to, uh, with the same, using the same box and everything.
Alright, I have to eat.
I also remembered that I'm still confused.
Alright!
There it is.
Duh.
The surprise gift slash announcement.
Whoa!
Oh, and I can put it back on.
And then, whoa!
And then it's back on.
What is it, Toki?
What's in the box?
All right.
Whoa.
What could it be?
What's this?
That's the concert!
Yes!
But what do you mean by, by this, Toki?
I believe, in 30 minutes, I will be giving you guys a little birthday treat.
And I will be re-streaming the concert version, the Anime Expo version, one time.
One time.
And then after that one time, it will be privated until the polished version comes out.
Um, I decided to treat you guys in this, um, in this, but it will only be shown once, before it's fixed.
Before we, before we fix it.
So I do have, I do have, I do have rules though for this.
Um, it will be, okay let me, actually I made a waiting room for it already.
So let me make, make the waiting room.
I'm going to make the waiting room un-private now.
But in 30 minutes at 7 p.m.
PST, this concert will be shown once on stream before it gets privated.
And then we'll have an after-party concert where the true birthday celebration.
So today was actually a three-parter.
So there's more stuff on the third... there's three streams.
So the third stream, I'll go into depth about this concert.
And I'll be showing behind-the-scenes videos of this concert.
So let me un-private this right now.
Boop!
So these are my... these are my guidelines for this concert.
No full recordings or read the uploads of any sections of it on YouTube.
So as I will be uploading a full polished version with new songs and fixed elements to it.
Because it was done within a month, so there's some like rushed aspects to it.
So that's why I don't want... I don't really want that to be the archived version.
But because it's my birthday, I decided to treat you guys for this.
The existing uploads of the venue version at Anime Expo is okay to keep up.
You can post small clips and GIFs and pictures on any social... on social media.
So you can do that for social media.
If you want to put small clips, GIFs, or pictures and screenshots, you can.
Just no full recordings or upload... or re-uploads of any sections on YouTube.
That's all I ask.
And this will be privated right after the concert is over.
Um, as I want the polished version to be the archive.
But yeah, like I said, I decided to give you guys like a little birthday treat of this version.
Um...
So yes, let me link the...
I'll link the waiting room right now.
Uh...
For you guys.
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Here is...
This is the waiting room for, uh...
For the concert version.
Um...
But yes!
I'm sorry to the gragoons who are not awake to watch this version.
But do not worry!
We will have...
Uh...
We will have a polished version at a later date.
And it will be a bigger improvement.
Because like I said...
Um...
This...
Was rushed up...
This was done in a month.
I won't say like rushed rush.
But...
Um...
It could be a lot better.
And I am a professionist.
And I do want...
The version that will be archived...
To be the one...
That's like...
You know...
To my standard.
In a way where like...
I want...
Like there's like little mistakes here and there.
And that's why I was like hesitant about uploading...
This version.
Because I know people are gonna like...
Be like nitpicky over it.
So...
So that's why...
Um...
That's why I was like...
I...
I was like a little...
Hesitant in like showing you guys...
This version.
Because when you see the HD version of it...
You'll...
Like...
For me...
I'm like a perfectionist.
So like...
I was like...
Aw man...
I wish this was changed.
Or that was changed.
Or like...
This was brushed up on or fixed.
But...
I do...
Um...
I...
I decided...
You know like...
Fuck it.
Um...
I do want you guys...
Uh...
For those who weren't there...
You know...
In America...
To be able to see this.
Um...
I decided to be...
To show you guys...
Uh...
To give you guys the opportunity...
To see...
Um...
The concert version of this.
But only once.
You get to watch the rare...
Raw...
Unedited version today.
And this will be in...
30 minutes.
Um...
But I will be uploading...
A director's cut...
Slash...
Polished version later.
Oh...
Um...
But yes...
Because of it...
There is a third stream.
Which is the...
After party.
So let me...
I forgot to...
Unprivate that one too.
And that's where we...
Actually can chill.
That's what I was like saying.
I had to like...
I didn't prolong the outfit reveal part.
Because there's so much to do.
There's so much to do.
Today.
So I didn't prolong...
The outfit reveal.
Cause I want...
There's so many things...
I wanted to like...
Show you guys.
There's so many things...
I want to talk about.
And everything.
So I try to, like, make sure that, you know, I get to say everything before it's too late for everyone.
Before, like, it gets too late.
But, alright, so...
So the after-party is out as well!
Yay!
The after-party waiting room is out!
Anyway, guys, I'm going to prep for the concert stream.
So I will see you guys...
Wait, I'll see you guys in 30 minu- well, yeah, I'll see you guys in 30 minutes.
And then in another 30- in an hour.
30 minutes in an hour!
So, I hope you guys enjoyed the part one of this three-part stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed the part one of this three-part stream.
I will tweet out the concert stream as well.
For those who are on Twitter, we're like, what?
That was the announcement?
So I'll be tweeting that out right after.
But before... I will talk about the credit.
Okay, I'll show you guys the credits real quick.
But I'll split... I wanna go in-depth for the credits later.
Oh my gosh, I forgot to do... Oh, this is... I knew I forgot something.
I forgot to put, like, an outline.
This is a little hard to see.
Alright, I'll show this on part three.
I forgot... Let me put an outline on this.
If you guys wanna see the credits of everything, I will show that on part three of the stream.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Oh wait, no, don't head to bed.
Go to the concert stream.
Anyway guys, I'll see you there.
Bye everyone.
I'll see you there in like 20 minutes.
Bye guys.
Bye.
I'll also show the intro video.
Oh, actually.
No, I'll show the...
I'll show that in part three.
I'll re-show that.
But I'll see you guys later soon.
Bye bye guys.
Bye.